vamos con el problema 51 en el problema
51 necesitamos un dibujo que va más o
menos así es un triángulo es un
triángulo y en ese triángulo nos indican
la medida de algunos ángulos este mide
bueno de hecho de todos este mide x
grados este de acá me de ye grados y
este de acá me de zeta grados vale y con
esta figura lo que nos piden determinar
es cuál es el valor de z muy bien vamos
a ver que nos dan de opciones de
información en el enunciado 1 nos dicen
que x es igual a 139 x es igual a 139
aquí tenemos información oculta a ojo
recuerda que esto de aquí es un
triángulo y que en un triángulo la suma
de los ángulos siempre es de 180
entonces pues con tener este dibujo de
un triángulo implícitamente nos están
diciendo qué
x y z es igual a 180 vale bueno entonces
en el inciso 1 nos dicen que x 139 y
sabemos que x maceta es igual a 180
entonces sustituyendo x más aquí arriba
déjame tomar otro color para que se vea
a qué me refiero
entonces poniendo x más aquí arriba como
139 obtenemos que 139 más z más z es
igual a 180 y de aquí podemos obtener el
valor de z que no nos importa solo nos
importa que podemos obtener entonces el
inciso 1 es suficiente y el inciso 2 ya
no sé qué color estaba usando creo que
este de acá el inciso 2 dice dice que
gemma z es igual a 108 gemma z es igual
a 108 y con este de acá por sí mismo no
podemos hacer nada verdad y ni siquiera
juntando lo con el de acá si juntamos la
información de la suma de los ángulos
con el inciso 2 sólo nos queda el valor
de x pero pues no sea de zeta que es el
que queremos no podemos decir nada
una cosa interesante bueno deja primero
le pongo su tache cita de que no es
suficiente pero una cosa interesante es
que si juntamos los dos podemos
encontrar el valor de x y y z con este
de acá encontramos el de zeta al
juntarlo con este encontramos el de ye y
finalmente sustituyendo aquí arriba
encontraríamos el de x entonces eso
suena padrísimo pero bueno no es lo que
nos pregunta entonces el inciso 1 es
suficiente y por lo tanto la respuesta
es a la respuesta es a muy bien vamos al
siguiente problema al problema 52
en el problema 52 nos dicen que x y z
son números que no son 0 entonces x y z
no 0 10
también pudieron haber escrito esto de
otra forma lo pudieron haber puesto como
x zeta el producto es distinto de 0
tales y los tres no son 0 su producto no
es 0 si el producto no es 0 ninguno de
ellos puede ser 0 pero bueno son amas es
un dato curioso y lo que nos piden es es
determinar si x z
si x z es igual a 12 vale queremos
queremos ver si esta igualdad se da
bueno en el inciso 1 en el inciso 1
nos dicen que x cuadrada jay-z es igual
a 12 veces x 12 veces xy muy bien aquí
lo que vamos a hacer es cancelar xy de
ambos lados es más vamos a hacerlo por
partes primero cancelamos x nos queda x
y z es igual a 12 y ojo pudimos hacer
eso porque porque x x que x es distinto
de 0 podemos dividir entre un número
sólo cuando es distinto de 0 y luego de
aquí podemos dividir entre ella y nos
queda que x z es igual a 12 y pues ya
está verdad x 7 es igual a 12 pudimos
responder esta pregunta de acá pero ojo
lo importante es que pudimos hacer las
divisiones porque x jay-z son distintos
de 0 entonces este de acá es suficiente
le voy a poner palomita de que por sí
mismo basta vamos a ver qué nos dice el
enunciado 2 en el enunciado 2 lo que nos
dicen es que se está entre 4
7 / 4 es igual a 3 / x 3 / x con esto
podremos determinar si x 7 igual a 12
pues si mira multiplicando cruzado nos
queda que x z es igual a 12 o bien lo
podemos hacer por partes multiplicando
por x nos queda que x se está entre 4 y
es igual a 3 y multiplicando por cuatro
nos queda que x z que aquí se cancela el
4 nos queda 4 por 3 x z es igual a 12
entonces una vez más x 7 es igual a 12 y
este inciso fue suficiente para
comprobarlo vale bueno entonces la
respuesta sería de de cualquiera por sí
misma nos permite responder la pregunta
vale ahora vamos al 53
el 53 53 nos dicen una cierta compañía
cuántos empleados tienen o sea queremos
determinar cuántos empleados hay en una
compañía déjame ponerle así en el bueno
le voy a poner empleados y empleados va
entonces pues ok el contexto es que es
una compañía y queremos encontrar el
número de empleados vamos a ver que nos
dan de información en la información uno
nos dice si tres empleados son
contratados y todos los que están se
quedan entonces habrá al menos 20
empleados déjame ponerle a los empleados
y entonces si contratamos 33 entonces
habrá al menos 20 entonces más 3 es
mayor o igual que 20 esto de aquí
todavía no nos dice cuánto vale es
verdad simplemente nos dice que es mayor
o igual que 17 vaya esto lo podemos
reescribir restando 3 de ambos lados
como que es mayor o igual que 17 pero la
cantidad de empleados podría ser
o 500 vale entonces todavía no sabemos
cuánto vale
con esta de acá vamos a ver qué nos dice
el inciso 2 el inciso 2 nos dice sí si
no se contrata de empleados adicionales
y tres de los que están ahorita
renuncian entonces habrá menos de 15
empleados ok entonces hay que tener
cuidado y -3 renuncian 3 es menos aquí
es menor escrito que 15 15 muy bien
entonces estoy acá como lo podemos
reescribir pues sumando tres de ambos
lados nos queda como es menor menor que
18 y aquí va la cosa interesante mira
por sí mismo esto de aquí pues tampoco
nos dice cuál es el valor de podría ser
1234 cualquier número hasta 17 incluso 0
entonces pues esto no funciona pero si
juntamos las dos si juntamos esta con
esta obtenemos que es por un lado es
menor que 18
y por otro lado es mayor o igual que 17
ahora podrías decir pues qué tal que es
17.5 17.2 eso no se puede porque es una
cantidad de empleados entonces tiene que
ser un número entero que es mayor o
igual que 17 entonces puede ser de 17 en
adelante pero menor que 18 entonces pues
no se puede de 18 en adelante entonces
de aquí concluimos que es igual a 17
entonces juntando ambas partes de la
información podemos determinar el valor
de pero con la información de cada una
no podemos y por lo tanto la respuesta
la respuesta a este problema es sí creo
que ya hace mucho que no teníamos una c
va problema 54 déjame bajar un poco
problemas 54 lo vamos a hacer en color
verde va problemas 54 dice cuál es el
valor de n en la ecuación siguiente
entonces nos piden determinar el valor
de n y tenemos que se cumple la ecuación
menos 25 más 19 más n más n es igual a
ese sea y es una s bueno queremos
determinar el valor de n bueno en
realidad no queremos determinarlo solo
queremos determinar si lo podemos
determinar queremos ver si podemos hacer
las cuentas no queremos hacerlas pero
bueno es bueno este reescribir esta
condición de forma que podamos entender
mejor los enunciados que nos dan
entonces para encontrar n lo que voy a
hacer y deshacer esta resta menos 25 19
que es menos seis menos seis más n es
igual a efe y ahora voy a sumar seis de
ambos lados tenemos que n es igual a s
más 6 entonces si alguna de las
condiciones nos da información de efe
podremos encontrar el valor de n
bueno vamos a ver los enunciados en el
enunciado 1 nos dicen que ese es igual a
2 pues claramente esto nos permite
determinar el valor de n verdad y ese es
igual a 2 entonces en ese pues 26
entonces nos quedaría én igual a 8
entonces esta de acá es suficiente por
sí misma vamos a ver qué dice el inciso
2 el inciso 2 dice que n entre s es
igual a 4 y aquí están relacionando n
con ese entonces seguramente podremos
despejar ese y bueno ponerlo en términos
de n substituir aquí arriba y con eso
encontrar n
vamos a hacerlo para que me lo creas
pero voy a cambiar de color para que no
sea tan monótono entonces multiplicando
por s de ambos lados nos queda que n es
igual a 4 s dividiendo entre 4 nos queda
nos queda que n entre 4 es igual a efe y
sustituyendo esto en la ecuación de allá
arriba nos queda que n
n es igual a n entre 4 n entre 4 + 6
aquí ya se ve que podemos encontrar en
verdad pero le seguimos todavía tenemos
algunos segundos
entonces multiplicando por cuatro nos
queda que 4 n 4 n es igual a n 24
restando n nos queda que 13 n es igual a
24 y dividiendo entre 3 nos queda una
vez más que n que n es igual a 8 vale
tus emisiones muy gary goleadas pero
bueno el chiste es que pudimos encontrar
el valor de n utilizando únicamente esta
información y bueno las hipótesis
iniciales que nos daban pero así lo
hemos estado haciendo todo el tiempo
entonces la respuesta sería de de
cualquiera de los enunciados por sí
mismos nos permite determinar el valor d